I think we've all heard of the word
bacteria let me make sure bacteria and
we normally associate it with kind of
negative things as you say bacteria
those are germs so we normally associate
those with germs and they indeed are
germs and they cause a whole set of
negative things or at least from our you
know kind of the the standard point of
view people believe that they cause a
whole bunch of negative things so just
let's just list them all just to make
sure we we know we know about them we're
all on the same page so the the bad
things they do they cause a lot of
diseases tuberculosis tuberculosis Lyme
disease Lyme disease I mean I could go
on and on they you know pretty much
anytime well I'll be careful here
whenever people talk about an infection
it's often caused by a bacteria can also
be caused by a virus an infection is
jeanna in general anything entering you
and taking advantage of your body to
kind of replicate itself and in the
process making you sick but bacterial
infections let me write that down
bacterial infections and this whole
perception of bacteria being a bad thing
is probably a good reason why almost any
soap you see now says antibacterial on
it anti bacterial because the makers of
the soap know that in just in
conventional thinking bacteria is viewed
as a negative thing and you're like okay
Sal I know where you're going with this
and you know bacteria isn't all bad
there are some good traits of bacteria
good for example I can make I could
stick some yogurt in some or I could
stick some bacteria and some milk and
it'll help produce some yogurt yogurt
sometimes spelled yogurt yogurt you know
and that's that's obviously a good thing
it's a delicious thing to eat you say
well I know I have bacteria in my gut
and my gut helps me digest food and
these are all true but you're like look
you know what on balance I still think
back
is a bad thing and just so you know I'm
not going to take sides on that debate
as I tend to avoid taking sides on
debates in these science videos maybe
I'll do a whole playlist where all where
I do nothing but take sides on debates
but here I won't take any size on that
but I'll just point out that you are to
a large degree made up of bacteria it's
not just your gut it's not just the gut
or the yogurt you might eat or the
plaque on your teeth which is caused by
bacteria it's this kind of film that's
created by bacteria that eventually
causes cavities and whatever else and
it's not just the pimples on your face
the pimples on your face bacteria
actually represents a majority of the I
guess you call of the cells on your body
so for every forever and this is a kind
of an astounding fact for every one cell
on the human body every one human cell
one human cell so these are all cells
that you know all have your DNA in them
and they all have nucleuses and i'll
talk about in a second you have 20
bacteria 20 bacteria now your response
there says okay that's fair enough but
these bacteria must be much smaller than
the human cell so it must be a very
small fraction of my mass and you're
right it's not like we're mostly
bacteria by mass although we are mostly
bacteria by actual cells but even if you
were take out all of the water in your
body then by mass bacteria is going to
be roughly 10% of your mass of your mass
so I weigh about 150 pounds I've got 15
pounds of bacteria walking around with
me so you know one we always kind of
think ourselves is like you know the
bacteria is riding on us but to a large
degree we're kind of in symbiosis we're
kind of two creatures are not just two
creatures two types of creatures living
together because I don't have just one
type of bacteria on we have thousands of
types of bacteria on me there's a huge
amount of diversity and we're just
scratching the surface in terms of the
the number and types and diversity of
bacteria that exist so I've talked a lot
about bacteria
and hopefully this fact right here will
make you realize that they're super
important to just our everyday existence
and just to make you know make sure we
understand the magnitude of this in a
previous video and I and I look this up
again we have on the order of we have on
the order of 10 to 100 trillion cells
human cells trillion cells so for every
one of these we have 20 bacteria we're
talking we're talking about having on
the order of 200 to 2,000 trillion
bacteria on us at any time trillion
bacteria and I'm a hygienic person I'm
no you know I take showers daily and
that's even me it's not like you can
somehow eliminate them and even more
it's not like you even want to eliminate
them
but that's fair enough you're probably
asking okay Sal I'm convinced that
bacteria are important what what do they
actually look like and there are these
small unicellular organisms may that's
my bacteria right there and they're
different from the cells that make up us
and when I say us I'll throw in all
plants animals and fungus --is fungi and
the big difference or the one that
people noticed first is that all of the
Eukarya you Karia which includes plants
animals and fungi all of their DNA is
and can is inside of a nucleus a
cellular nucleus so that's the nucleus
right their nucleus and all of our DNA
it's normally in its chromatin form it's
all just you know spread around
something like that on in bacteria which
are you know what people originally just
classified on whether or not you have a
nucleus in bacteria there is no membrane
surrounding the DNA so what they have is
just a big a big bundle of DNA so they
just have this big bundle of DNA it's
sometimes in a loop all in one circle
called a nucleoid nucleoid
nucleoid now whenever we you know we
look at something we say oh we have this
thing it doesn't there's this assumption
that somehow we're superior or we're
more advanced advanced beings but the
reality is is that bacteria have
infiltrated far more ecosystems and
every part of the planet then you care
you have and there's far more diversity
in bacteria in bacteria than there is in
Eukarya so when you really think about
it these are the more successful
successful organisms if we were to have
you know a if a if a comet were to hit
the earth god forbid the the organisms
more likely to survive are going to be
the bacteria than the Eukarya than the
ones with with the the the large not
always larger but the organisms that do
have this nucleus and have membrane
bound organelles like mitochondria and
all of that we'll talk more about in the
future bacteria for the most part just
big bags of cytoplasm they have their
DNA there they do have ribosomes because
they need to have to they have to code
for proteins just like the rest of us do
and some of those proteins they'll make
some for from bacteria they'll make
these flagella which are tails that
allow them to move around that allow
them to move around they also have these
things called pili pili is plural for
pylus or p lists
so these pili and we'll see in a second
the pili are kind of the how the
bacteria are able to do one form of
introducing genetic variation into their
into their into their populations but a
big and actually I'll take a little side
note here I'm pointing out bacteria is
not having cell wall there's actually
another class that used to be
categorized as type of a bacteria and
they're called archaea and I should give
them a little bit of justice they're
always kind of the stepchild
RRK archaea they used to be called
archaea bacteria but now people realize
they've actually looked at the DNA
because when they've originally looked
at these they said okay these guys also
have no nucleus and a bunch of DNA
running around these must be a form of
bacteria but now that we've actually
been able to look into the DNA of the
things we've seen that they're actually
quite different but all of these
both of these both bacteria and archaea
are considered prokaryotes pro carry
oats and this just means that no no
nucleus no nucleus and more general I
mean this is what most people refer to
but more generally they don't have these
membrane bound organelles that our cells
have now the next question you might say
is well how does these bacteria
reproduce and for the most part they do
something not not completely different
from mitosis although I want to call it
mitosis we call it binary fission binary
fission binary fission I'm not going to
go into the deep mechanism here but the
idea is fairly simple I have a bacteria
right here it replicates its DNA so it
starts you know it'll have to these
nuclei oh dear and then the cytoplasm
essentially splits or you know you can
it's kind of a form of cleavage right
there it splits and then you have two of
them you have two of them then and then
each of them they can code for the
proteins necessary to produce all of
their extra appendages the flagellum
which is this long tail like thing that
can help it move and it's actually
fascinating because it's operating at
such a small scale but you can still
kind of get these this motor movement
going on even at this very very small
scale using very primitive I want to say
primitive because that's making a value
judgment on these things but using you
know that these flagellum are on the
order of several nanometers on the order
of tens of nanometers wide so I mean
it's not this you know you don't have a
lot of atoms to deal with but you're
still able to get this kind of wave-like
motion that can move the bacteria around
now you're saying hey Sal on that first
video on on evolution you told me that
you know bacteria we see evolution every
day and bacteria is one example you know
when we use antibiotics they we think
it'll help eliminate bacteria but that
one bacteria that has some type of
resistance it'll survive and so it is
more fit how do these guys get variation
well the one way and this is a way
everything can get variation is they can
get mutations mutations and bacteria
replicate so quickly they reproduce so
quickly that even if even if you know
you have a mutation is one in every
thousand times by the time you have a
million bacteria you'll have a thousand
mutations so you have mutations but they
also have this form I don't want to call
it sexual reproduction because it's not
sexual reproduction they don't form
gametes and the gametes don't fertilize
each other and then produce a zygote but
two bacteria two bacteria can get near
each other near each other and then one
of their penises penises I'll do that
right here so the P lists are these
little structures on the side of the
bacteria they're these little tubes
really one of the penises can connect
from one bacteria to another and then
essentially you have a mixing of what's
what's inside one bacteria with another
so let me draw their nucleoid they're
nucleoid and then they have these other
pieces of just DNA that hangs out called
plasmids these are just circular pieces
of DNA plasmids maybe this guy's got
this extra neat plasmid he got it from
someplace and it's making him able to do
things that this guy couldn't do maybe
maybe this is the R plasmid which is
known for making a bacteria resistant to
a lot of antibiotics and what happens is
is that bacteria is actually there's
mechanisms where the bacteria know that
hey this guy doesn't have the our
plasmid and we're just beginning to
understand how it actually works but
this will actually replicate itself and
give this guy a version of the our
plasmid you could also have these things
transposon x' and I should make a whole
video on this because we have transposon
stew but there's parts of DNA that can
jump from one part of a fragment of DNA
to another and these can also end up in
the other one so what you have is kind
of it's not formal sexual reproduction
but what you just sensually has as a
connection and these bacteria are just
constantly swapping DNA with each other
and DNA is jumping back and forth so you
can imagine that all sorts of
combinations of DNA happened even in
within a what you used to call one
bacterial species and very quickly can
turn to multiple species and become
resistant to different things if this
makes it resistant to an antibiotic then
it can kind of spread the information to
produce those
resistant proteins or whatever to the
other bacteria so this is kind of a form
of introducing variation and so when you
when you transfer stuff via this pilis
or the plural is pili this is called
conjugation bacterial conjugation kanjou
and Gatien now the last thing I want to
talk about because this is something
that you've heard a lot about are
antibiotics antibiotics a lot of people
they get sick the first thing they want
to get is an antibiotic anti biotic and
an antibiotic is just a whole class of
chemicals and compounds some of them
naturally derive some of them not that
kill back kill kill bacteria so now if
someone has is gone undergoing a surgery
and there's you know they get a cut
instead of them having to worry about
getting the infections they'll take some
antibiotics to prevent the the bacteria
from growing on them but the question is
where does this you know how is this how
is this discovered or where does it come
from
and actually came from it came from
Alexander Fleming let me write him down
very important because the discovery of
antibiotics is in my opinion the most
important discovery in medicine so far
so Alexander Alexander Fleming he was
studying I think it was Staphylococcus I
forget which bacteria was but it was in
a petri dish he was in a petri dish let
me draw a petri dish it's a little
circle there's some nutrients that the
bacteria can grow on so let's say the
bacteria you know it's it's growing on
this petri dish and he went out and he
came back into the room and he saw that
some mold some some fungus had had grown
on this kind of bluish greenish fungus
had grown on the center of his petri
dish on the center of his petri dish and
the bacteria there was kind of the space
around and the bacteria couldn't get
close to it and this mold this this
fungus was called this Penicillium
Penicillium fungus he was able to figure
that out he took a sample of this and
then he cultured it which means letting
it grow and then seeing what it is
this was Penicillium and he figured out
that gee this this
longus must have something some chemical
that it's emitting that's essentially
killing the bacteria around it it's not
allowing the bacteria to get near it and
so that led to the discovery of
penicillin penicillin
I see Panna penicillin and now that he
discussed was in the late 20s 1920s now
once you know by time World War two came
around now people had gunshot wounds and
had to get things amputated whatnot but
for the first time they could actually
give people antibiotics and not worry
about or they probably still worried
about it but didn't have to worry about
this thing as much as they did before
and now you know if you have a bacteria
if you have tuberculosis or Lyme disease
or anything the key the the the
treatment it all involves taking
antibiotics and there are many many more
types of antibiotics now coming from
many many more different sources but the
general idea is the same
you want to kill bacteria although you
don't want to kill all bacteria because
some of its good in fact we are made up
of a lot of bacteria there's even
there's even I don't know if I even
mentioned this early in the video
there's bacteria on our skin that helps
take up oil and moisturizes and make our
skin nice and supple so you know the way
you think about you could view them as
negative or you could view them as
positive or you could do them is
something in between but the really
amazing thing at least in my mind is
that we're living in symbiosis with them
I remember I saw a Star Trek episode
once where you had these you had these
people you had these people and you know
there was some alien race Jean Jean Luc
Picard had had you know they ran into
them they looked very humanoid like that
but it turns out let me draw this human
that they had these little bugs in their
brain stem so they had these big insects
in their brain stem and these insects
started infecting the crew of the
enterprise and making people and they
were controlling their brains and making
them act weird and whatever not and this
seemed like a very bizarre alien concept
right of some creepy crawly living in us
and in affecting our brains and
infecting us in some ways but if you
really think about it we are doing this
and it's not just with one little bug
it's with it's with on the order of
trillions hundreds of trillions of bugs
are with us every day and they make us
us I mean I'm here
according videos with along with or
maybe I should even say the bacteria is
recording videos or it's maybe partially
responsible for controlling bacteria and
as if it's known that the bacteria can
even affect our mental state there's a
bun a whole bunch of research now that
certain types of bacteria can cause
schizophrenia actually syphilis does
bacteria can cause depression a Lyme
disease
Lyme disease it's known that when you go
into later phases of Lyme disease it can
cause it can affect the mental condition
of the person who's who has the
infection so it affects every part of
who we are I mean it would be hard to
even talk of being a human being without
that the 10% of our mass or the you know
two thousand trillion cells of that or
two thousand trillion bacteria that
really make us us